all right pftpm friday edition wrapping
up with some of your best questions
submitted through twitter rsv hill 31 i
probably didn't pronounce that correctly
i'm sorry if that's the case who's the
next viking to be traded yesterday it
was yannick way to the ravens shireen
anyone jump out on that roster as a
candidate to be shipped off by a vikings
team that knows it's over in 2020.
mike they have plenty of candidates and
i think they should trade whoever they
get the best deals for because this is a
team to me that looks like it's going to
be rebuilding they don't have much cap
space as we know so i think they should
trade some guys and and the one that
really jumps off the page to me is kyle
rudolph you know they signed him to that
four year 36 million dollar deal before
last season and they haven't used them
enough he's only playing 70 of the snaps
this season not doing very much at all
for the vikings i think he could go
somewhere and help somebody so he would
be a guy i think would would be first on
the list but i think there's plenty of
candidates on that team that teams will
be interested in
we're gonna have kyle rudolph on the
program on tuesday unless it falls
through under circumstances like this
sometimes the interviews do fall through
one in five during the bye week with the
trade deadline looming and a veteran
player he may not want to comment
because that will be one of the
questions harrison smith's another guy
that you look at now you have to factor
in all the cap consequences that hit
next year but with next year's cap at
175 possibly
you you don't want to start burning up a
bunch of dead money now that goes into
next year unless you really get some
great assets in return i'd love to see
them trade kirk cousins frankly that's
not going to happen the cap consequences
would be enormous but
you know there are some guys on that
roster that maybe the time has come to
move on i think they recognize this
combination reload and rebuild isn't
working it's kind of like trying to
change a tire on a moving car and i will
say this
my one little piece of vikings history i
can contribute back in 1990 the vikings
were one in six and they reeled off five
straight wins and got to six and six so
it's possible then they lost the next
four and finished six and ten though so
what the hell but you're not truly done
with seven teams alive for playoff spots
you're not truly done and i'm fascinated
shireen by the possibility of one of
these teams getting a seven seed this
year or next year in either conference
you get the seventh seed
and your playoff game
is against the two seed which is a team
from your division
that is going to be one hell of a way
for the two seed to have to break into
the playoffs playing a team that knows
it very well right out of the gates
well you think of all the divisions
where that could happen mike i mean you
look at the the nfc north you look at
possibly the uh nfc of the afc nfc north
both of those divisions that very well
could happen there's several teams there
that you look at that that that could
happen
and so yeah it's going to be crazy um
when those teams have to face off in the
division you could see the two seed
going down in the first game because
they don't get the bye this year
moments ago we got the confirmation that
we will have kyle rudolph on tuesday so
i will ask him about whether or not the
vikings can't turn it around i don't
know 40 is there anybody in the cowboys
locker room that can step the hell up
and be a leader shireen you know that
team as well as anyone who should it be
who could it be
well you know dak prescott is there
later and he's not going to be back this
year he is going to be around the team
but it's normally either the quarterback
or a veteran guy who's been a starter
and and has been the voice like a jason
witten and obviously they lost jason
witten to the raiders in the offseason
so he's not there anymore he started
looking around that roster there aren't
many guys but i'll say this
when the the anonymous quotes came out
this week about the coaching staff sean
lee asked to be on with the with the
dallas media he asked to be a leader uh
for that team and he stepped up and he
talked the other day and he hasn't
played a game this year so i think sean
lee is the prime candidate to be that
guy
well we'll see what happens with the
cowboys we'll see what happens with uh
that team this weekend as they try to
get to three and four and boy they would
at three and four that's one of those
where the vibe around the team that it
that we've seen would not mesh with
three and four three and four would be
pretty damn good through seven games
given everything this team's been
through
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports